Okay, it's time for a quiz. Play around with the programming
exercise on JSON and answer the questions that we're about to
look at. Now you could certainly do this by looking at
the data manually or just by knowing things about artists, so of
course doing a little Googling. Please try to do it by
writing code, building on the code that you were given in the
previous exercise. Okay, let's take a look at the questions for
this quiz. So, the first question is: how many bands named "First
Aid Kit" are there? Next, see if you can find the Begin-Area name for the band
Queen. Then find the Spanish alias for The Beatles. Dive into the data
and find the disambiguation for Nirvana. Now,
the Nirvana I mean here is the band
that Kurt Cobain served as front-man for.
And finally, please answer the question, when was
One Direction formed?